ok watch
herzlich willkommen zum video was du auf
der gamescom aufnehmen ich bin gerade
auf der gamescom wohl nicht dachten
heute summen
was könnte man fünf video auf der
gamescom aufnehmen ich habe mich früher
gefragt habt ihr lustigen schild die man
auf der gamescom machen könnt und ihr
habt reichlich geantwortet
jede jede menge treat deswegen machen
wir heute eine zuschauer
frank volk war sie aber mächtig viele
fans von euch gestellt wurden jeden fall
machen wir das jetzt wie im kino ich
lese dass ihr eure trees for mache dann
was in dem tweet steht blamiere mich bis
auf die knochen und einfach das was
jetzt hier
wir haben wir detlef d soost bin ich
tatsächlich als spinne das so ist die
spinne etwas pflaster geworden aber das
kommt jetzt
was aber wenn ich jetzt gleich
unmittelbar jetzt genau hier
follow me round jazzbands
dank schneller für diese challenge sie
schrieb schrei lang lebe der inhalt ihr
die ohren zu
na du hier wieder ruhig
ich kann aber jetzt schon im boden
versinken wollte nicht vergraben worden
schreibt in den boden vergraben in die
kommentare
wenn ich mich da klappt china schreibt
hinterleuten herlaufen und die immer so
antippen dann so tun als wäre man das
nicht gewesen
was machen eigentlich kein problem
wir müssen jetzt jemanden suchen im
laufen hinterher und dann kommt man den
anderen
22 grad nicht
ein
fr
stella
wir müssen uns an der koptischen
christen wissen
bei der ab
mit
das wissen
schwester und sein besucher ganz
aufgeregt nach serbien mit umfragen
so wie wenn zwei aufrecht
ja genau ja nicht der peinlichsten tag
meines lebens überhaupt nicht drücken
eine sache noch zoll menschen direkt
fragen
könnt ihr recht auf vor
christa xj sagt je zu irgendwelchen
menschen und sagt omg bist du nicht der
sg können wir bitte ein foto machen ich
bin ein großer fan der caps also müsste
wahrscheinlich stein
von der anderen kamera wie ich gerade
abgeblitzt das wirklich
wenn ich warne davor zurück einfach
drauf
wir müssen unbedingt auf sg finden
neben der typischen kamera die man kauft
er sei es das für mich ja
ich hab mal mitgespielt aber
ich glaube der war zuerst denken
angedacht
laut
nein
da war
na klar
bist du nicht auskennt dann machen wir
nochmal
die gäste
mu
dort hat er sagt
recht so
die jungs
sind sie eher bereit
weißt du wo das grab
das fleisch wird
die mutter
bitte
wissen sie über das gras bleibt
genau jedes
flo texte schreibt verein socken stöhr
das thema
werden
ich will den helfen
aber die können sich nicht mehr selbst
helfen
ein freund
bei jobs raum
hmm